all right guys here she goes kate
houston
with the green jackets on the t for the
13th houston is four
under for the day oh my gosh it's a par
four
dollars left contrary to what the
instructor said i think it is all about
the finish
one more one more okay fair enough we
were talking in her ear
which is distracting that's the eight
news now mulligan yes we need to have
silence
silence for caking silence get the music
going
on the t par 5.
there it is there we go kate houston
golf club redemption i don't know if i'm
ready
for the masters quite yet i might need
to get a couple more lessons in here
but if you want to make a lesson make a
reservation you can go to topgolf.com
las vegas and celebrate the masters play
as you watch
reporting live from topgolf this morning
kate houston 8 news now
i don't know okay that was pretty good
you don't get a green jacket for nothing
we'll erase the video of that first one
it never happened
it's all about the second one it's a
mulligan we threw it out it's all good